my name is Stuart Holloway and this talk
is running with scissors live coding
with data I want to start by saying how
thrilled I am to be back at one of the
most fun software conferences I've ever
been to strangely hope you guys are
having a great time so far as well I
usually don't do a BIOS slide but as I
was thinking about this when I felt like
it was somewhat of a big deal when I
noticed that I had been doing this for
30 years so I've been writing software
for 30 years in a variety of programming
languages from assembly kind of at the
bottom of the abstraction pyramid to
closure and small talk maybe at the top
of the abstraction pyramid and I have
taken on just about every role one can
have in a software project including
often being a developer founding a
couple of companies managing other
people being responsible for operations
running a support team being a
stakeholder being a tester and being a
teacher in particular I've worked at a
place that I created for 15 years now
and as a result of that I have had to
live with the consequences of my past
choices for quite a long time so a lot
of this talk is informed by living a
life where you you know I try to have it
not be a brownfield but living in a
world where you are reaping the
consequences of things you did five and
ten and more years ago I'm a developer
on closure the programming language and
very briefly on closure script I worked
on it during its first six months of
life but anyone who's ever seen me do
anything in a browser knows that you
know once the foundations were laid I
needed to move along and I'm the lead
developer of the atomic database in
those roles I have worked on a daily
basis with rich icky pretty much every
day for the last eight years he is the
designer and architect of all those
things and deserves the lion's share of
the credit for anything that they do and
I deserve some of the credit when they
have bugs so I say something about
closure closure is a dynamic functional
hosted Lisp when rich started working on
closure there wasn't a lot of demand for
that if you had hold focus groups hey
you wouldn't find people in 2006/2007
saying you know what you know what we
really
here is a functional Lisp that would be
that would be super awesome what a
strange idea this closure thing is and
yet this crazy thing has happened and I
want to take a minute to enjoy it
because it's hard to believe and as
closure continues to succeed we just
keep moving the goal posts but I want to
stop for a minute and say look if you
look at the Stack Overflow surveys for
happiness for salary for salary per unit
experience closures killing it if you
look at the red monk quadrant
you know nobody would have said ten
years ago somebody was gonna stick a
dynamic functional Lisp in the top right
of any analyst quadrant for anything and
that is amazing and I just want to get a
quick show of hands how many people here
have programmed closure professionally
look at that nobody would have believed
this would be possible
now you can applaud go ahead that's good
and so the question I want to ask is a
little bit about how that happened I
think a lot of it for many people was
Rich's evangelism and the videos that he
did very early on and has continued to
do and conference keynotes and also the
rationales that he provides for these
things so you can go to the website and
you can look at what we mean when we
talk about being dynamic or functional
or hosted or a lisp and those things
have been remarkably stable
over a decade now and so there's a ton
of motivations and reasons to come and
give this closure thing a try but
there's not a whole lot of okay I'm
sitting at the keyboard now what in fact
if you read the website it's almost like
sort of okay boy this hammock is super
comfortable I just hopped out of it I
have this whole program in my head what
do I do next and this talk is about that
so this talk is all about closure dev
workflow that I use and I will just say
right now
I'll caveat supply there is nothing new
Under the Sun there's not a single thing
that I'm gonna show you today that
hasn't been done different better cooler
in some other language or some other
person or whatever but I've also watched
people struggle to be effective in
closure and I think it's good for us to
have a conversation about the things
that we do when we're sitting at the
keyboard so let's start with running
what I mean by running let's not pick up
the scissors quite yet running means
that you develop the program inside the
program the program is running the
entire time maybe the program runs only
once during its entire initial
development and you turn it off when
you're completely happy with it and this
is really the Lisp secret sauce right
the read eval print loop and it's
important to deconstruct that a little
bit it's right there in the acronym that
repple is a composition of three
functions read which takes text and
returns data an eval which takes
programs that does something and print
which takes outputs usually data and
turns them back to text again and when
people start looking at Lisp there's one
box on here that they usually go to and
they get all excited
right they see that box in the middle of
eval called macros and they're like oh
it's on I'm gonna go in there and do all
kinds of crazy things and years ago I
made the mistake of saying what the
first rule of macro Club is and and
people took it as dissing of macros so
I'm going to try to amend that today and
say that the first rule of macro club is
don't forget all the other clubs shown
on this slide
macro macro Club is a very cool club and
it's fun to hang out there but it's
really fun to hang out in these other
clubs as well and so I'm going to give a
few examples of ala carte usage of the
other function the functions that make
up the repple so this is a la carte
usage of reed so this is from my
personal financial management software
which I wrote for myself enclosure using
closure and atomic it's completely
bespoke and it knows specific details
about the banks and credit cards that I
have and so forth but the when I sit
down to actually process data in there I
get a stream of data coming out of a
database that represents things that
banks and credit cards know out of about
me or about transactions I've performed
and I want to do things to those
transactions I want to annotate them in
some way so this is a little bit like an
inverted ripple right there's a loop
where data is coming from the world and
I respond to it and that's what that
call to read is and so what this is
showing is how easy it is to do what
some people would call an internal DSL
in a language like closure right I have
a whole dialog that I made up that I
have with my data that's entirely
specified and closure data so I didn't
have to write a parser or come up with
any grammar or anything like that I just
said look I have lists and vectors and
keywords you know so a keyword that
categorizes a transaction and a map with
a keyword and a string in it categorizes
the transaction and adds a comment and
so on and so forth and then that perform
categorization action function is
polymorphic processing that's driven
entirely by data so there's never any
classes or interfaces or anything like
that made that's just a simple example
of that
read is a function you actually call it
doesn't just happen on your behalf
inside the repple similarly with print
this is a tiny little snippet of code
that reinstalls your repple running the
pretty printer instead of the regular
printer so I see people all the time
I've seen people I've sat down with
people at strange leap in the past 24
hours and had them print some horrible
ugly thing at the repple and then stare
at it and try to understand what it
meant and I agree with you that would
suck don't do that so this is just the
tip of the iceberg of the kinds of
things you could do if you wanted to
customize printing of course this next
slide shows Moorea cloud now if you
followed along efforts to teach
beginners programming in particular
teach them closure this is a nifty
little environment it's at Marea cloud
on the web that is based on the ideas of
Maria Montessori Montessori School Fame
if your kids go to Montessori school or
if you did and what they've done here is
they've built an entire literate web
environment that's commingled texts and
places where you can type in code and
when you type in code they send it off
to an evaluator and then they've
completely overridden print on the way
back so that the printing actually
doesn't show you closures error messages
which are somewhat famous let we shall
we say and so this says and I don't know
if you can read it but I will post the
slides later
you know you type in 1+1 and it says oh
I see you haven't done prefix notation
yet that one is in function position not
what you want instead of you know
whatever closure would do which is like
you know class cast exception jump back
in the hammock or something like that so
the repple is a powerful thing that
being said there are a lot of concerns
that people raise about it common
concerns that I hear are I already have
a shell isn't this just the same as that
or typing into our Apple sucks or I saw
somebody make spaghetti code in a
wrapper once and I don't want any
spaghetti code well just the shell is
not enough and we've already seen one
reason why that text to code and
execution and data backs to text are all
separate functions that are composed any
language that you sit down with that's
not a lisp has to answer these questions
and if it doesn't break them apart like
this then the answer is complected
everybody drink
but additionally you have the ability to
turn text to data how much time do you
spend in non-lisp languages taking data
from primitive formats that don't have
fidelity to your language and turning it
into your language and then turning the
data back out again but equally
importantly and this is the top couple
of rows here when you're working at the
repple your program semantics and your
interactive semantics are identical a
closure program is the result of
sequentially evaluating a bunch of forms
this is true even when you layer
abstractions on top of that like files
and require and reload and all that sort
of thing when people build shells on top
of existing languages it's usually the
case that those languages have a set of
rules about how code comes to be a live
program and those rules tend to be let
me say more elaborate than evaluate one
form at a time they tend to have things
like well there's preambles and
declarations and you have to consider a
whole file before you can decide that
it's a program and so on and there are
benefits to that but I think that there
are clear benefits to having this
environment that you Devon be
interactive and be identical to the
environment in which your programs are
made as a concrete example of the kinds
of problems I'm alluding to here we can
consider the new shell that Java has
Java added a shell and they added it
specifically to address the problem that
students computer science students
really don't like Java and they don't
like Java because when they're first
especially if it might my daughter is
taking AP Computer Science right now and
she was exposed to a tiny bit of
JavaScript and a tiny bit of closure
before she started her class which is
preparing her for the AP exam and now
it's all in Java and she's like what is
this why do I have to do all these
things before my program will start
running and so J shell was designed to
address that but of course they had to
go back and say well what are the
semantics of being a shell my job is not
an interactive environment so Java has
classes and methods and all these things
that have to be evaluated in a context
and so they had to make up a bunch of
rules and so there's you know a dozen or
fifteen different rules about how the
shell is not your program
I don't want to write my program in that
shell because that's not my program it
doesn't provide a suitable environment
to live in
the repple is not about text entry and I
see this one quite commonly I think this
is a very earliest thing that people get
over but when you are working at a
repple of course you can type at a
ripple right there's nothing that says
there's a law that you can't but that's
not how Lisp programmers have ever
worked right you work in your favorite
tool you can work in in cursive and
IntelliJ or an Emacs
or vim or space max or vs code whatever
you want and you have all the
affordances of a modern editor there and
then when you want to evaluate forms you
send them to the repple what about the
spaghetti code problem lots of people
sit at shells and make spaghetti and it
gets ugly fast I get it
this is a real problem but the problem
here is not the repple the repple makes
you faster an imperative makes spaghetti
so rep a plus imperative is faster
spaghetti right if you're a net negative
producing developer and we speed you up
that's worried we've just made things
worse that's bad this one's pretty easy
and I'm actually not going to spend any
time at this conference talking about
why functional programming is important
I'll just give you a metaphor right
functional programming at the repple
helps you baked bricks faster things you
understand how they're going to work
they always work the same way and you
can compose them to build your system so
the spaghetti argument is true but it's
only true when you're combining a shell
with the sort of ball of mud ball of
spaghetti programming that we're
accustomed to an imperative and most
object-oriented programming what about
the scissors part when you run your
program what are you running a lot of
programming languages make you think of
your program as a thing
that is your program that you've got
going on and then maybe you make a
special program to evaluate your program
right you're on your unit tests or
whatever but this is not
really the sort of focused way at all so
the scissors are about cutting your code
and your data down to exactly what
you're working on and so the style here
is I'm calling for today shopping these
names around task-specific dev and it
begins quite often not with code but
with is with example data and then it
moves quite often not from example data
to code but from example data to
generated data so we start with
imagining the data that our system is
going to manipulate and then and only
then interactively at the repple develop
and test functions when you're doing
that you're not going to write the
entire universe from scratch load what
you need to make your function go and
load precisely what you need to make
your function go right load just the
namespaces you need it's not your entire
program it's not necessarily what's
going to happen when you run main or
whatever when you're in production and
if you need to build a little bit of
custom UI to help yourself out along the
way UI that's purpose is only to assist
you as a developer so here's an example
from this is taken from one of the old
Ruby quizzes still on the web I don't
know if they're still adding them this
is quite a few years old I ported this
to closure when I was first learning
closure and so this is a designing and
then building a system to play
rock-paper-scissors so the first thing I
do is make some data the Dominator map
is a map from things to the things they
dominate or things that are they're
dominated by these get to confuse about
that so the rock is dominated by paper
scissors are dominated by the rock the
paper is dominated by scissors and then
moves is another piece of data it's just
a set of legal moves note that we have
not introduced any new data structures
haven't made any new types we've just
walked up and said look we have
perfectly good generic data here key
words can enumerate things and maps and
sets can collect things then when we go
to actually develop a function that
tells who the winner is we can test that
function interactively and we can use
spec to generate a bunch of sample data
so rather than maybe writing in a unit
test for a single example I would rather
generate a hundred examples or in this
case 10 because that was what fit on the
screen and just eyeball those examples
and say hey
is this does this look right obviously
you can still add tests I'm not
advocating at all that you don't write
tests but when you're doing this initial
exploration it's valuable to say instead
of looking at one example show me what
my program is going to do with a hundred
examples now in this particular program
I ended up not needing to load any code
but in more elaborate things I do this
is the set up stanza that I use when I'm
doing my personal finances so there's a
require that installs a bunch of
namespaces that I need and then it
connects to the database where I have my
data and then I'm ready to go and this
is not in some sense I mean there's no
I've never actually run this program
from Maine not that there's anything
wrong with that but this is just a start
at the repple build the thing you need
and then move along with that the next
thing that people hit with this is as
soon as the data gets large they're
pounding their head against a wall of
text do not do this I've already showed
pretty print closure also has print
table closure has an inspector or you
can send your data to a spreadsheet or
you could make HTML or you can create a
picture with it but don't do things like
this
so here I've just made up some junk data
it's a bunch of alpha beta values
between 0 and 100 and it's deliberately
install an dated so that you can't
necessarily read it because you don't
want to try to look at something like
this but you don't have to do this the
inspector is six inches away from you
when you're programming enclosure stand
up the inspector and call inspector
inspect table now I will tell you that
if you're coming from almost any other
lisp closures inspector is quite
primitive and I'm astonished that
somebody hasn't made one or even ten
more better ones than we've seen out
there and I know there's stuff I'm not
trying to diss things that've been made
because I know there are things out
there that are cool but I think part of
the reason for this is that many people
came to closure not from lisps and they
didn't have high expectations in this
area they weren't used to having these
things in other environments and that
may be a contributing reason and I hope
that this talk will agitate somebody
into making a cool inspector but you
know so I don't like the inspector very
much that's fine
I like spreadsheets just fine the
spreadsheet is six inches away from you
take your data throw it
into a spreadsheet look at it there take
your data and throw it into Mathematica
look at it there take your data and make
a picture of it this is a co-worker of
mine and cognate echt Jeb who has made
spec vis suspect vis is a program that
will take closure specs and turn them
into graphics and this is the example
from the site there's obviously these
kinds of pictures there's all kinds of
fiddly things that you might want to do
and make them domain-specific but the
thing that I would say about this is
that the amount of effort to produce
these data visualizations is small
enough to fit inside of a single story
card right we're not talking about
making a general-purpose inspect all the
things thing we're talking about making
a special purpose show me exactly what I
need to do to help me do what I'm doing
right now is this too much work I gave a
talk last year about repple driven
development in Chicago at the Chicago
closure users group and I actually never
noticed the hacker news thread on it but
while I was researching this talk I went
back and found it and I found this
statement with a red ball I have all
this stuff to do blah blah blah and this
is not nearly as efficient as an IDE
that's been set up to which I say put
all the stuff that you wrote to make
your Apple exactly perfect for you
inside of a do block and now you have a
single key you know get back to where I
was when I want to do that thing again
and there are examples of this lying
around all over the closure repository
itself they are what I call rich comment
blocks a rich comment block lives at the
bottom of a clj file it contains some
sample data it contains some sample
invocations of the code that's in that
library and and this is incredibly
important it records a durable history
of the dev process which often includes
things not done sort of by definition
that things that are not done are not
going to be in your code that they were
in your code you'd have to admit that
you did them probably so the things that
are not done but it's quite often the
case and if you look through most of the
names faces in closure they have a
little comment at the bottom
these comments are rich because they
provide rich detail about the
development process and because they
were written by a person named rich and
here's just one as an example this is a
slightly modified version of the one
that's at the bottom of set clj I've put
a due block around the top showing that
this is this part that's setting up the
state you would need to try this out I
think that rich didn't even bother and I
hypothesize that he didn't even bother
when he was doing this because he
touched it so few times that it just
didn't matter but I've put the do block
around just so you can see the advanced
configuration capabilities that closure
provides and then you have the
expedition log writing software is a
journey not because I've had to live
with the software I've written over the
last 10 years I'm always coming back and
looking at it and I love having these
expedition logs at the bottom of files
they take me right back to where I was
when I was doing it and of course if you
put them I'm not saying you'll have to
have to put them in the file with your
shipping code but if you do if you
choose to put them there then they're in
source control they're not sequestered
in somebody's IDE configuration and
because it's all made of data you can
manipulate it in particular it's about
time for someone if I was going to let
you speak to say what about tests well
obviously this style that I'm laying out
today could be could cohabitate with any
way of writing tests you've ever done
right so I'm not necessarily saying you
have to write tests differently but
having adopted the style of working at
the repple I write my tests entirely
differently after I have made a set of
repple interactions I add some
validation checks to those interactions
and then I have a program that runs them
as if I were at the repple so it just
grabs a file that likes is a log and
runs through that file evaluates all the
forms printing out the results and has
maybe some checks and sanity checks
where it can blow up if things are wrong
and I release this I don't know a year
or two ago
as a closure library called transcriptor
transcript errs source code
is smaller than the build file for
almost any other testing framework let's
say that again trend search through
source code is smaller than the build
file for almost any other testing
framework and the reason is it doesn't
do anything right ultra transcriptor
does two things actually does three
things maybe it it has the ability to
run a file by which I mean evaluated a
form at the time printing out the
results it has a single function called
check which compares the result of the
most recent evaluation using closure
spec so unlike testing frameworks I get
to stand on top of a ton of great work
that's in closure I don't have to worry
about I mean every testing framework
eventually discovers writing its own
return value comparison language right I
got back a return value I want to
compare it to what I think is right a
lot of basic tests that's an equality
comparison but as you write more
complicated tests it's no longer an
equality comparison I have all of close
respect to help me do that that's the
code side but the scissors also apply on
the data side when you're writing
programs in closure at the repple you
model information about the real world
as maps with key words as keys and
values as values I have three maps on
this page all three of them happened to
be about me one of them I know I'm that
kind of person sorry one of them is my
name one of them is information about my
github account and one of them is about
my Twitter account imagine an alternate
reality that I'm gonna call slot based
programming and the way slot based
programming works is that before you can
use any information you have to
enumerate the complete set of what that
information is going to be I'm gonna use
a keyword struct this is not any actual
programming language but I'm gonna use
the keyword Strutt struct and then in
this programming language I make slots
so the person has a first name and last
name the github account has an ID and
the date joint and the Twitter account
has an ID and the day join whatever well
guess what all your data manipulation
scissors are gone now you don't have
generic data anymore each one of these
struts requires its own custom
special scissors to manipulate it and
that would be bad enough to put me off
wanting to do this but it gets even
worse when you start combining things
because all three of those maps were
information about me well in closure if
I wanted to put them together I can use
my scissors
I can call merge and because closure has
qualified names as a first class concept
when I merge things if I'm planning on
playing in the big pond where I'm going
to get data from other sources that I
don't control I am using key word eyes
keys so the github slash ID does not
conflict with a twitter / ID so I can
take data in the world that I've
discovered is about the same entity and
merge it together because I didn't pour
concrete on my data I care about and
have good facilities for discovering
information about my data at runtime and
this is not sequestered in a reflection
API this is a primary part of this
programming experience so here I have a
little helper function that says give me
all the keys that have an unqualified
name of whatever and so then I can walk
up to the information about me and say
which things look like identifier z'
like their local partners ID and the
important thing here is that i can
combine things in context specific ways
as soon as you model an entity you're
going to have a context in which you
know more about it as soon as you model
an entity you're going to have a context
in which you know less about it so what
happens if I walk up to the github
information about me and I say select my
location
I say select Kies return a map with just
the location is that a perfectly good
factor a broken struct I want to work in
a world where it's a perfectly good fact
so to run this down slots model a closed
world they undermine generic miss the
undermine ad-hoc usage and scaling of
dev effort is combinatorial because once
you find two pieces of information in
the world are about the same thing you
make a third thing that's the
combination of those and then you make a
fourth thing and a fifth thing and so on
now I have deliberately laid this
comparison out as starkly as possible I
am NOT denying the possibility of middle
ground here that there's a broad middle
ground but I see a lot
people working in a style that really
looks like the left hand side side of
this table and in fact so much so that
we have a special industry name for that
unnecessary combinatorial effort you're
running program is tangible tangible
means that you can query it it means
that you can transform it and it means
that you can program it closure has a
bunch of functions that are about doing
this we don't have to go through the
details all evolve them but you can call
functions that say find me documentation
you can call functions that say give me
the source code you can call functions
that say enumerate all the VARs in this
namespace or all the VARs in this
program and you can transform the
program as you go so you can finish an
experiment off and then transform the
program away from it right that was an
interesting experiment and without
leaving the program you can discover a
mistake repair the mistake evaluate that
form again and continue programming
without leaving the program and there
are some more advanced carving things
here as well like removing namespaces
entirely and so forth that you might use
occasionally I want you to imagine what
this process is like when you are for
example co-developing two lives I often
find myself working in the code base of
a client and a server where in order for
them to work correctly they have to
agree about things when I'm doing this I
load both the libraries from the repple
sometimes in the same process often in
the same process that doesn't have to be
the case you could have more than one
ripple process I jump right in and study
the data I use the in in s form to move
into a namespace and look around I use
def forms to redefine things I write
ad-hoc programs on the fly usually very
short but little tiny programs that help
me explore the situation when something
goes wrong I make changes one def form
at a time and when I'm done I leave the
set up for my exploration in a rich
comment at the bottom of the file
I worked like this all the time it has
come to my attention that there is
another workflow advocated by another
Stewart called the where he wrote a blog
post Stewart Ciara about five years ago
when he was working with us at cognate
echt or maybe even was relevance back in
that at that time and what's called
workflow reloaded and this is the
component library enclosure and I think
that there are what a half dozen
competitors to component now and that's
perfectly fine if you were working that
way great but I do want to draw out the
contrasts workflow reloaded tends to
operate at one level of abstraction
higher than what I'm talking about
it's working at the level of your
project and your files and your
namespaces and and this is something
that I don't have in this workflow
it offers tooling to help you keep track
so it says you know what I'm gonna make
a change in this namespace that implies
cascading changes to that namespace in
that namespace in that namespace and I
will help you reload them I don't have
any tools like that to help me as a
result the way I work is much more
targeted surgery I go in and I make a
change in that namespace and I make a
change to a single form I don't reload
the namespace and if that change is
going to cascade other places then I
have to think through that and often
that's not a problem often this
technique helps me focus enough that I
don't have to worry about it but let's
think about the moments when it is a
problem let's say I'm working in you
know form foo in namespace a and I
realize that that's gonna have a
cascading effect I might be better off
to track that down in my head and think
through it and ask the question why is
this effect cascading so much I think
that by working at a lower level you put
yourself it's that old adage above
something hurts do it all the time right
when I'm working at this level when
things slip into becoming unnecessarily
dependent on each other it's in my face
and so it provides a pain point that I
think in my experience leads to having
less couple code that being said by all
means both of these things have a ton of
utility
what about GUI debuggers well GUI
debuggers are what I call the
off-the-rack version of what I'm talking
about here they have a lot of improved
visibility right they add a lot of
visibility they give you cool widgets
they tend to have relatively limited and
special abilities to transform things to
say I want to work on my running program
while I'm in here although they
certainly do there's you know fixed bug
and restart at breakpoint and things
like that but when they have those
things they tend to be special they're
not part of my program they're not part
of my debugger and as a result they tend
to have no or very weak program ability
so the UI widgets in my debugger are not
functions that I can call typically that
being said I can imagine a world where
these things you know come more together
and I am sure that there are more
programmable debuggers out there but in
my experience debuggers do not feel like
scissors they're not things that I can
take and write programs out of and build
things on top of last thing I want to
talk about this closure spec data is
alive in your closure program you are
not putting it in slots you're making it
manipulating it seeing what it does and
spec allows you to add specificity
without throwing away your scissors
you're still using the generic
manipulation tools that can cut any kind
of data you're still using a so shinned
dis oh Sh and select keys and things
like that
but you can add specificity when you
want to and this is terrific for
brownfield development so I gave a spec
talk at Strange Loop a few years ago I'm
not going to recapitulate that now I'm
going to focus on a few aspects of spec
that are particularly helpful when
you're working in an existing code base
and this is based off of a sample
project that I did last year exploring a
closure library that wraps a Java
library called C ljx chart so C ljx
chart wraps a java library called X
chart and it makes it closure ish by
which I mean it turns all the
interactions with charts into generic
data which is a beautiful thing this is
why I picked this library there are
dozens of Java charting libraries and
closure wrappers for each but this one
had a particularly clean I solved a
problem with this library which is I
went from it was an imperative thing to
you make a single call with data and
make stuff so that's great
imagine that I have to be a programmer
who's going to maintain X chart or clj X
chart either one and make changes to it
I want to understand how it works and I
want to dig in deeper than what I can
see from static analysis of the code so
I start by making some really basic
predicates a chargeable number is
something I'm going to need to have it's
a number in its finite and an x-axis is
a collection of Charta bus' that has at
least one thing in it and a y-axis is a
collection of tribal members that has at
least one thing in it admittedly I could
say most of that even with Java is very
primitive types but then I move on to
arbitrarily complex types and I'm using
types here not in the static typing
sense but in the generic sense of a type
represents a set of possible values I
can write any program I want to decide
what's a possible value so the predicate
at the top here access counts match it
turns out that there are multiple
different ways to specify axes in the
data language in X chart and so this
predicate is verifying that all the
different things that have to have
identical cardinality have identical
cardinality and then some of the data
rendering Styles have requirements on
the ordering of the data so one of the
axes has to be ordered ascending and so
the second here second thing here is a
multi method saying that for this
particular style of data this data has
to be ordered
once I've written specs like this I can
explore the domain so I can exercise
data here I'm exercising some line
widths and then exercising generators
and in a few hours I was able to get all
the way up to exercising code so this is
a randomly generated chart every aspect
of its configuration was randomly
generated from spec including the names
it's comparing hitpoints and global
warming and Emacs users and pirates and
vim users I'm not sure you know what we
get from that but the interesting thing
about this is when I want to get power
from spec I can use as much power or as
little power as I want
and so having made all these predicates
about the world I can turn them on
selectively so I turned on a little bit
of instrumentation and I call XY chart
this was a bug this is a bug that the
Java program doesn't catch so the
underlying Java program doesn't catch
and the data transformation layer
doesn't catch basically there is an
invariant about the data and the way it
catches it is that the swing aw t thread
blows up which is not very useful right
your thing doesn't get drawn it blows up
but I can turn on this instrumentation
and I could turn on a dev time only I
could say you know what we're gonna use
this in development to make sure we're
not making this mistake so what can't
take away from this the first thing I
would say is that spec is an enormous
addition to the tool belt of working
interactively and it's totally
compatible with the interactive tangible
programming style that I've been talking
about here secondly specs do not need to
be complete or exact it's not a type
system it's not a thing that you have to
jump over before your program is allowed
to do anything it's entirely the
opposite for that in particular the
specs worked for you not you for the
specs when I was writing the specs for
this library I was not using them to
definitively say how the library worked
I was using them as tools to get exactly
one piece of information that I wanted
and so I know and the specs are clearly
marked as well this spec doesn't
actually cover the entire truth of this
guess what specification probably never
does so might as well admit it up front
and you can use spec to add support
where you want it need it perhaps most
amazingly when I started exercising this
within one minute of generating charts I
uncovered a bug not in CL JX chart the
closure program nor an X chart the Java
program but in the JVM itself so as soon
as I started using generative testing so
small testing take away from today's
talk if you test only by examples start
generating data for your tests because
you will find things that are going to
surprise and pain you so what we've seen
today is running work inside your
program from a rebel with scissors tools
where you can precision cut your code
and your data to exactly the size and
shape you need to do your job the job
you're doing
coding alive against a tangible runtime
where you're in your program invoking
your tools instead of living in your
tools invoking your program and I'll say
that again cuz it's cool you're living
in your program invoking your tools
instead of living in your tools invoking
your program with live data that you can
explore and extend using spec that's
running with scissors I'm not going to
take questions up here today because we
are right at the time but I will happily
stand outside and take questions for as
long as people want to talk I assure you
I can talk longer thank you very much
[Applause]